I don't know like are you not jealous
because I don't want to share my partner
at all I have my polyamorous people on
the left spotlight and my monogamous
people on the right spotlight walk
forward if you agree stay there if you
disagree humans are naturally
polyamorous the way I think of myself as
polyamorous is even more broad than
sexuality and it's just simply like you
know I can see the beauty in and adore
and love qualities of an infinite number
of people if I just recognize myself in
another person yeah we don't just love
one kid we love multiple children we
don't just love one friend maybe wanting
this loved one job we're in LA he'll
probably up 12 jobs month to 3 of us
here many people have gotten divorced
and remarried and it's like I'm on my
fourth marriage you know like how does
that work out it's like that's really
sorry nervous that that is kind of like
polyamory over time okay it's just a
circle non-ending when you could have
just been true to yourself and had those
multiple relationships whether they had
a piece of paper or not
I understand that a lot of marriages
fail but at the same time I feel like a
lot of people don't put in the effort
that they should if people are willing
to try and do the best that they can and
try to be the best for this one person
it can definitely work a lot of people
in polyamory want to use the divorce
example as a reason for why they're
polyamorous and they understand but at
the same time it's you can't really know
until you try it and a lot of people
that are monogamous think that polyamory
is just all sex you know I've been with
the same guy for six years and I've
never felt like I needed to be with
someone else and if I did I would have
just left him how does that sounds I
just can't imagine like feeling equally
for two people we have to be equal
though it doesn't know usually you like
I mean for lack of better words like
rank your partner's like wait you have a
primary partner so in most even in
polyamorous relationships I'm in an open
relationship not polyamorous which isn't
about just sex but it isn't I do have a
primary partner who I live with and who
I spend time with if I share bills with
a nice share a family with and then I
have other partners maybe who I share
dinner and drinks with or we have a
similar career interest and someone
would just love making out with so I
think that there are yes there's
compartmentalized ways and there are
people who do have two equal partners I
think that's probably the minority
versus the majority just like the
monogamous relationships nobody's
marriage is the same that's what you
make it is the boundaries you make it's
your relationship it's not nobody else's
relationship I got a high five you want
that one took the church right there I
why did you hesitate before coming in
because I had to think about how I'm
answering that question I was thinking
about someone outside of myself and it
occurred to me that I can answer this
question in a different way and that's
been a very big theme in my life the
last few years coming out of a divorce
in a monogamous marriage 20 years of
monogamous relationships and and the
theme of my life from for myself right
now is finding love with myself and
being in love with myself I feel like
throughout my relationships I have found
a lot of love for myself
like all of the girls that I have dated
and my girlfriend now currently like
have all taught me so many things I feel
like that's one of the main things in
that relationship like you love someone
so much and then you learn from them and
they learn from you and you guys grow
together it was just like a beautiful
thing my name is olive Tina but I go by
alia and honestly as a person I don't
think I would be able to give someone
what they want and what they need in
their relationship if they had more than
one partner I've been married for two
years and but I've been with my wife for
over eight years and she was my only
girlfriend so it's about is monogamous
as it gets
yeah but very much still in love yeah I
love her more every day in a weird way
my relationship it allowed me to love
myself more when I was with someone who
totally accepted all parts of me who was
like be that it's beautiful it's sexy it
allowed me to love myself more and
that's I think the beauty of open for me
is its complete acceptance for me and my
decisions there is no well you can't do
this or well your urges are bad or this
is bad about you it's be who you want to
be let's talk about it I actually read
about a polyamory like when I was in my
early 20s I'm reading about like this
sounds so like who's read something
mothers were resonating with me like I
just didn't realize it was that much of
an option I didn't see much of a model
in society I thought well even if I want
that how would I find someone else who's
into the same things I am and in the
last couple years I've been really just
saying like I need to explore this and
to find community I'm not someone who
says I don't believe in monogamy as a
matter of fact having a chance to really
explore both sides has given me an
understanding appreciation for both and
also understanding the limitations of
both myself there is a good reason why
most people are monogamous I don't know
like are you not jealous because I feel
like that's the main reason why I
wouldn't be able to do that I don't want
to share my partner at all yeah I don't
share it's like I am with you and you're
with me and you know we're together and
we're growing and if you don't want me
anymore and you want to go explore other
things go and explore them but on your
own you know I think that's crazy
just because in every other area in our
life you have to control jealousy
jealousy is not a attribute to be proud
of to say I'm a jealous person like if
you're at work you can't be a jealous
person function well at the office you
can't function well in your family or
with your friends as a jealous person
and so why in this one area of your life
do you say this is where I get to be the
person that I can't be anywhere else
the idea of jealousy of I'm afraid
because I've put so much it's kind of
like the slot-machine approach I've sat
at this machine I put in so many
quarters I want to you know get reap the
benefits but if this is someone that you
love does that extend to that if he said
this is someone that I think might be a
better fit if my husband said I found a
different person that I want to be with
and she's fulfilling a need that you
don't or can't then I'd be like okay go
be happy with her like it's not natural
for me to be like okay let's the three
of us work this out and to me that
jealousy is just rooted in the fact that
you're completely intimate you've made a
commitment to each other and this is the
person that is basically like your
second half having that jealousy for
your significant other is beautiful and
in a way I think monogamy is a practical
choice because it's safer sexually one -
it's probably a lot simpler and it's
it's prepackaged I mean it's like here's
a set of rules that has been created for
you hundreds of years ago
here's what love looks like and if that
feels comfortable for you it's easy but
monogamy isn't easy you know monogamy is
hard like being with someone and being
with them for 10 15 50 years it's very
hard you have to find ways to love your
partner for truly who they are all the
good and all the bad and you don't have
someone else to turn to when you want
something new you have to find it in
your relationship you have to find a way
to spice things up you have to find a
way of making conversation where you
know everything about each other why
don't we have one friend why not just
one friend why do you need multiple
friends at all I mean most of us
probably have 10 friends 20 friends
5,000 Facebook friends why why not just
have one Facebook friend because you
don't build such a strong connection
with a friend you build a strong
connection with a partner because a
partner gets to know everything and
every single thing will be because
there's different levels of friendship
but like when you're in the relationship
with someone you explore so many more
things in so many different facets of
your day because at some point you will
move in together and you know you'll see
what everyone does like day to night and
you'll get to know everything about them
you don't really get that with one
friend I do have like a best friend
right but the reason he's my best friend
is because he's different than every
other friend I have and if I have
something really really serious really
really important I'm going to him first
but you still have other friends sure
and I equate that to what she was saying
earlier about having a primary partner
for example you know you could have a
primary partner that you have intimacy
that you live with you have sex with and
you may have like let's let's equate
that to your best friend and then there
could be someone else that you hang out
and you play baseball with you do other
activities with you know and I could
have another person we make music
together and we do things and yeah when
we have sex once in a while - it's
interesting that you know I think from
the traditional model the fact that I
would have any physical connection with
this other person is what distinguishes
it as a issue if my partner wanted me to
I would consider going to the other side
Oh
[Applause]
I was monogamous for a lot of my life
and that was for you know the reasons
that were felt authentic to me at the
time and I've been non-monogamous for
some time now which has been authentic
for me for this time and I think that
for me the important thing is always
keeping an open mind and realizing that
life is constantly evolving I think one
of the things I disliked about monogamy
when I was in monogamous relationship is
all of the you need to or you should or
that we have a pre-arranged agreement of
what loving each other means and if you
don't obey that it's over and I wanted
to give my partner a true open
experience and so if I'm gonna say to
you it can't be monogamous well how is
it really open because there is a
condition on there of like well this is
the only way this is going to work so
it's always open to me means open for
discussion
can I jump in and what you said about
like loving and you know fully accepting
someone I just know that I as a person
wouldn't be able to be in the
polyamorous relationship and keep myself
happy so if my partner were to suggest I
would say you know I don't think I'm
capable of doing that and I would still
love them I would support them I would
want to be friends with them I would
want them to be as happy as they can be
even if that doesn't involve me in their
life I think what the strength that
non-monogamy has over monogamy is that
we're saying who are you who am i let's
figure out something that makes sense
for us versus this is what I was told
love is let's try and do that thing I
don't feel like I live that way because
someone told me to I just don't have the
want to add other people and if you if
you don't have that desire yes authentic
to you yeah and I think that so many
people on this earth have the desire and
they think they don't have the option my
name is Jasmine I actually married my
very first boyfriend
we just eloped and we got married about
two years ago we've been together ever
since a good sex life is necessary for a
good relationship
if sex dies from the relationship and
your love and lust for each other kind
of dies then you might be better off as
friends and partners as friends sex is
so much more than just physical that it
makes a big impact in how I feel in my
relationship if I don't have sex I'm
gonna feel like disconnected like
there's something off in our
relationship ultimately I mean I talk
about sex for a living it's a big part
of my life it's a big part of my reset
if I'm gonna have a sex would you undo
it myself like I really enjoy it orgasm
has ridiculous amounts of health
benefits and it just feels great so I
love the physicality of it but I also
think that every person should like
really define one of the top five things
you have to have in a relationship and
for a lot of people sex doesn't hit that
top five and if it doesn't that's okay
you know you can still make a
relationship work without sex being a
priority but if you're someone like
myself you can't I'm in the same boat
with you like I've always been a very
like sexually driven person an
explorative person and and all pretty
much all the monogamous relationships I
was in I had never found someone that
would say matched my kink so having a
partner that's like really on the same
page with me as explorative and open as
I am is really like pretty much at like
the top one or two things that I would
say in a relationship for me
success and everything in life if the
sexual tension is there awesome but what
happens up to the sex and the sexual
tensions is gone like was that it was
just sex the sexual tension dies out it
is kind of it can but that's the whole
point of like where people have to
rekindle it and they have to try new
things and they have to see what works
to make the spark come up again because
after we spend so much time with someone
and you know them so well it can get
lost but it's a continuous effort of
trying to make your sex life the best
that can be even an anonymous
relationship you still have to do that
like I don't think it's healthy to like
you to run out and look for other things
just because my primary relationship is
like not working like it's still me you
know that's that relationship still
needs work every relationship needs work
I think like sex is important I mean I
could just think of all the things that
sometimes like sex can just cure your
relationship and I don't know what it's
like to you know have a terrible sex
life so I guess take this with a grain
of salt but you know I don't think I
think about the amount of time you spend
with your partner right compare that to
the amount of time you have sex with
them I think a lot a lot more happens
besides sex and a relationship is I mean
it's like how much fun you have like the
intimacy you share conversations
everything right you know making sex not
just about sex like it's about
connecting to people so it's there's
someone right so I think it'll feel like
it's a space it's a really amazing space
to like to explore that connection in
the closest physical way you possibly
can
I feel like if sex was your first like
priority you wouldn't really be in
relationships you would be finding
sexual partners that fit you but you
wouldn't really care about anything else
so I feel like sex plays a big role but
also we're you know we're puzzles like
we have so many pieces and we have so
many needs and so many things that we
want to fulfill but sex I think is
pretty important for most people I've
been a track
to other people while in a relationship
oh well good for you okay I feel like
I've found people pretty nothing to a
point where I would even consider acting
on it I don't think you can only be
attracted to one person I feel like
that's really unrealistic I think it's
crazy thing to deny that because I mean
I think of every species existence as
survival and procreation so it's a think
that you can shut off that entire part
of yourself not to just I think action
is one thing because people have
successfully done that but in terms of
feeling or seeing some muscles
attractive that's crazy
apparently there is one person I just I
can't wrap my head I think it's totally
possible like we can all be wired a
little bit differently like we're all on
a different point in the scale and I
think our life experience also shapes us
to a degree as to where on that scale we
are know it so I know I'm gonna sound
crazy and I know it's like it's
something that I always have
disagreements with with my friends and I
think it is a little bit of what you
said you know being wired differently in
the beginning when I first started
dating my wife I was giddy giddy like in
love that like there was just this giant
bubble around a relationship but then as
we as we matured in our relationship we
got married what what I felt
uncomfortable with is looking at other
women like it actually made me feel
uncomfortable so the same way that I
trained myself to like if you want to
call it suppress or whatever other other
feelings and impulses I have I do the
same here so whenever I see a girl like
yeah I'm gonna walk down the street and
I'll turn my head or whatever and there
will be a girl wearing almost nothing or
whatever my what I've like built-in is
literally an instinct to just look away
and not think any further
what I think what's weird to me is like
the conversations I have with other
people will they'll look at someone of
the opposite sex find them attractive
and keep going and like mentally they're
having sex with like all these weird
things and that's like I'm really
uncomfortable for me
you're not saying like oh I was born
only thinking this one person is
attractive right you're saying you
trained yourself to be that way pretty
much okay that makes a lot more sense to
me I would feel incomplete without my
partner honestly if I didn't never met
my partner I wouldn't be the person I am
today
in the past year of dating my girlfriend
I have become so different and I have
learned so many things and they have
started taking care of myself so much
more than that was a year before I met
her and I feel like that has so much to
do with her and how she helped me
navigate this I had a really unsafe home
life and me and my husband got to know
each other in the 6th grades we were 12
I moved out when I was 18 me and him
like we had nothing we somehow made our
way over to LA like I honestly don't
think I'd be here like if it wasn't for
him oh man
I was married for some time so my whole
journey the last two and a half years
has been to feel complete by myself and
there are times like I really do desire
partnership I do desire a primary
partnership but I really think it's so
important to to be okay just being as I
am when the words incomplete I'm like no
I don't connect with that I connect with
I feel sad I'd feel hurt I would feel
disadvantaged maybe even but I'm still
going to be me and I totally understand
that we're coming from different places
and how we developed our relationship my
idea of a relationship is one plus one
equals three one complete person plus
one complete person equals a completely
separate third
I was gonna do this one but a completely
separate third relationship and this
would be incomplete ofcourse if we left
but the ones would still stand still and
be strong all right guys thank you so
much hey guys my name is Dan thank you
so much for watching middle ground we
love having these kinds of discussions
and we love to have you guys chime in on
what you guys thought about this episode
and what you would like us to do in
future episodes so if you like us
subscribe here and can watch more stuff
here thank you
[Music]